previously you've done a video about
garbage collection we need resources for
our programs to run but if we hang on to
those resources for too long that's a
problem because no one else can use them
and eventually we run out of memory
garbage collection before which is one
way of solving that problem the
difficulty with it as was kind of
mentioned in that video was that
that in itself takes memory and CPU time
to run which isn't great because if
you're trying to really run something
fast
you want to reduce the amount of
resources you're using as much as
possible so what we're going to talk
about today is a concept called raii
resource acquisition is initialization
and specifically we're going to talk
about how a language called rust has
built that into its language in order to
do the most it possibly can to stop the
programmer
making mistakes with memory
it's not a niche language but it's
probably not as
um well known as maybe some others so we
could show a brief hello world if you
want if I just make a new file here
hello.rs we'll start with the main
function
so there's a bit of sea like then is it
a little bit sea like yeah it definitely
wants to borrow from
that General type of C Java that General
syntax so if I just print hello world
here
and close it there so you can see that
the basic structure of it is going to
look very familiar we use FN to declare
a function instead of starting with a
return type if I wanted to return
something that would come after the
function name but the basic syntax of it
doesn't look too different the first
place where it starts to look a little
bit different from languages like C C
plus plus is the way we declare
variables instead of putting the type
first then the variable name then the
value we use this keyword let with a
variable name then I'm going to specify
the type so we're going to have an i32
and let's give it the value 10. so the
syntax is a little bit different
compared to what you're used to in C and
Java nothing too different so far the
first interesting bit comes in this is
the very first bit where rust starts to
try and stop you from making mistakes is
the fact that if you want to be allowed
to change a variable you have to
explicitly tell it you want to do that
there's a distinction between a normal
variable
and one that you're allowed to mutate if
I want to mutate a variable I have to
explicitly say let mute and let's have y
i 32 is 20. some other languages do this
as well like kotlin you've got a
difference between vowels and vars I
mean typescript you have let for a
mutable variable and const for one that
you can't change a few other languages
picking this up as well but that's the
first place where rust is going to start
trying to help you avoid making mistakes
if you want to change a variable you
have to explicitly let it
change the variable and that's going to
help guarantee that your variables have
got the values
you think they have I'm going to go over
to C plus plus first because it's going
to be easier to
demonstrate particularly to people who
haven't seen rust before
and then we'll switch over to showing
how rust has embedded that in the
language C plus plus you have to do it
yourself rust
it's pretty much built in the basic idea
of raii I've never I don't know if the I
don't know if there's an established way
of shortening that like you could you
could say I or Ray or rye
um
you know what I'm going to call it Rey
um if that's wrong
doubtless I'll find out in the comments
um so the basic idea of r-a-i-i is that
when you construct an object
you allocate the memory you need for
that object uh at the time you create it
and then you make sure it's destroyed
when the object is destroyed the idea
being then that the lifetime of the
memory you request is tied to the
lifetime of the object that's using it
means you don't have to worry about
freeing it elsewhere it means you don't
have to worry about allocating it
elsewhere
when I create my objects
I allocate my memory
when I destroy my objects my memory gets
freed for me it's a load off my mind as
a programmer it means I have much less
to worry about dangling memory
so if I do a brief example in C plus
let's have a class called Bob and Bob is
going to hold on to some integers for me
so it creates a class variable called n
which is a pointer to some integers now
we'll have the Constructor which is what
we're going to call to initialize Bob
and we're going to pass the number of
integers I want Bob to hold as an
argument
and then we can say this
n equals new
ins
X
okay so I'm saying that when I create a
new Bob I'm going to allocate enough
memory to hold X integers in C that
would be a call to malloc
um C plus plus has a a keyword to do
that so it makes it slightly nicer to
program but it's pretty much doing the
same thing underneath
then in my D structure which is
something that c has a Destructor is a
function that gets called whenever the
variable gets freed or it goes out of
scope and in my Destructor
I am going to delete this n
and finish my class
so what we've just done there as soon as
I create a bob I'm going to allocate
enough memory to store all of Bob's
numbers and when Bob goes out of scope
or Bob gets deleted Bob releases all of
the memory he was using to hold his
numbers and that's really great because
it means that I don't have to keep track
anymore
of Bob's memory I don't have to remember
that Bob's holding on to a load of
integers
soon as Bob goes out of scope
Bob drops his memory
produce the chance for memory leaks
that's awesome
the one obviously slight drawback is
that I still have to implement that
myself
I still have to write that myself
um so it still puts some of the work on
me as a programmer to remember to make
sure I've done that properly it doesn't
save me the problem
it just means I'm only doing it in one
place and just sometimes people cut
Corners with that
uh I don't know if people will cut
corners but it's definitely possible
where maybe Bob's holding a lot of
different kinds of memory for different
things if I just forget if I miss one of
those
um in the process or
this works great so long as absolutely
every class uses this pattern
if I forget to do that for something and
I just use a plain old pointer somewhere
then memory leaks can still happen
it it sort of if done properly it makes
it much harder to get memory leaks
but
it's still contingent on me as a
programmer doing my job properly
and implementing it properly mistakes
can still happen
right
one of the biggest actually is that this
stops one of the problems with memory
management it stops the problem of
memory leak which is where I forget to
free something
it doesn't solve the problem of what you
call a dangling pointer which is where I
try and access memory after it's been
deleted
this doesn't stop that so if I add a
method
to Bob that's going to be int pointer
get n and get in
is just going to return that pointer to
the memory that Bob's holding right
maybe I want to use that somewhere else
then in my main function let's have ins
main I'm going to make a new Bob
it's going to hold five numbers then I'm
going to have a int pointer that I'm
going to call X's that's going to have B
get n
then I'm going to delete Bob
and for good measure printf
the first number in X's
and I should probably include the right
header as well to make that compile so
what we've just done is we've created a
bob bob allocated his memory
we then got a ref got a pointer to that
memory so that I can do something else
with it
then I deleted Bob and Bob was very good
Bob uses
um Ray and deletes his memory problem is
I've still got another pointer to that
memory when I try and print out the
first element of that memory it might
work it might not this is a very simple
example I've not done anything else to
the memory in between so this will
probably work if this was a more
complicated program someone else might
have used that memory and then at best
I'm going to get garbage
at worst I might crash
right so Rey solves one of the problems
with memory managements but it doesn't
fix any of the others I've still got to
be thinking carefully about is my memory
still in use am I still allowed to use
it that's where Russ comes in and that's
where rust
tries to Hold Your Hand a bit and stop
you from making these kinds of mistakes
so
let's write a simple bit of rust
that's hopefully going to Showcase these
same sorts of things and then I'll
explain some of the concepts behind how
it's working firstly Russ doesn't have
classes as such he just uses struts
that's probably not too important but
let's have a struct called Bob
and Bob is going to have uh n is we use
a vector of I 32s
so same as the C plus plus version Bob
is going to hang on to some number of
numbers for me
um
it's got a vector and then when I make
Bob when I create a new Bob
uh let's just say we're going to return
a bob where n is
a new Vector so I'm making a bob
and when Bob is made he's going to
allocate some memory on the heat for me
to store his numbers and that's pretty
much all I have to do to make sure that
Bob's memory always remains valid
the way this works
every variable in Rust has something
called an owner right every piece of
memory has what's called an owner
and the owner as you imagine from the
name the owner is the person
who has control of that memory
every bit of memory has exactly one
owner
and like we just talked about with Ray
as soon as the owner gets deleted goes
out of scope or whatever all the memory
that the
the owner owns
gets destroyed
okay so there's our Ray principle and
that's just baked into the language
right if I now write a main function
for my rust program here let's have
let's n equal Bob
new
then
I will
end the function there I mean this is a
main function so I mean the program is
finished at this point so everything
gets freed but you know what let's call
this funk one and let's then call func
one from a different main function just
to make the case there we go we'll do it
like that so n was created inside func
one which is our new Bob Bob allocates
memory for his numbers once func one
returns our variable n has gone out of
scope so n gets deleted
the memory that Bob was holding gets
deleted at the same time
fine that's Ray this all hinges on
maintaining this property of uh one bit
of memory having one owner
okay we need to make sure that that
stays true because the moment a bit of
memory has two owners
the whole system collapses right and
that's when we can end up if we go back
to the C plus for a moment Bob had a
pointer to that block of memory that we
called n and then I also got a second
pointer to the same block of memory our
variable B owned that data
our variable X is also owned that data
and that's where the problem came in so
rust needs to stop us
from doing that there's a few way
Concepts that we want to talk about that
rust uses
okay
the first thing we need to talk about is
moving let's go back to Funk One n is my
new Bob and maybe I want to get a second
variable that refers to Bob okay so I'm
going to say let m equal n I'm allowed
to do that m is a new variable I'm going
to assign it to the same thing as n
okay
that might look like M and N are now
looking at the same memory but the first
thing that rust is doing behind the
scenes it's done what's called a move
because we're only allowed one owner to
a piece of data I sort of made a copy of
it
quite the opposite it is absolutely not
made a copy because that would mean well
you can get a copy but what it's done in
this case
m
is now the owner
okay and N not allowed to use anymore
if I was to try now and do something
with n the compiler would tell me that I
can't use n because the data has been
moved out of it
okay it's guaranteeing that at any time
there's only one owner for the data and
that applies to function calls as well
if I'm going to write let's write uh
Funk 2 and that's going to take
an argument of type Bob
and we're just going to print line
Bob Dot N and we'll have the first
elements of that
in our Funk one say let's
uh we'll call func to
with our Bob variable in other languages
when you pass something as an argument
to a function either it's going to make
a copy of it or it's going to give that
function a reference to it
but this isn't quite what we want either
we're going to end up with a duplicated
version of the data or we've got two
owners with a function same thing
applies our Bob gets moved into the
function
so now my B variable that I defined in
the function owns that Bob and in Funk
one if I try and do something with n try
and do the same thing I was doing in
Funk 2 the compiler will warn me can't
do that n has been moved so there's the
first step where we're guaranteeing
that our memory stays safe so that's
great right one owner at a time that
makes sure that when my variable goes
out of Scope when the owner goes out of
scope and gets deleted I know for a fact
no one else is using it
there are no dangling references to that
data
perfect
problem is sometimes I do want to keep
using my data after I've moved it
right maybe Funk 2 does something to n
but then I still want to keep using n
so that's when the second part of this
comes in which is this business of
borrowing in Rust in Rust you you have
this idea where you don't take ownership
of the data but you say just for a
moment
I'd like to do something with it I'm not
going to take ownership of it it's still
your data
but I just want permission to look at it
or maybe tweak it for a bit and I'm
going to give it back to you
and that's what we use uh borrowing for
and the way we do that in Rust is
through uh a syntax called referencing
so I'm going to edit Funk 2 now
so that instead of taking ownership of
my Bob it's just going to borrow Bob for
a moment
and then give it back
the way we represent that in Rust we
just stick an ampersand in front of the
type and that says that funk 2 gains a
reference to a bob it doesn't take
ownership of the Bob and then I put an
ampersand operator in front of the n as
well in Funk one and that says don't
pass n
into Funk 2 pass a reference to n into
Funk two so now Funk 2 has borrowed Bob
it can do whatever it wants with Bob
but then when the function returns Funk
1 still has ownership of Bob
because Funk 2 just borrowed him he
didn't take him up take control of him
completely and then if I was to compile
this funk one now
it would compile absolutely fine no
issues
so between this
um
moving and borrowing we make sure
we've got our Ray principles sort of
baked into the language and we make sure
we don't have any dangling references so
presumably if something's borrowed like
any good library book you need to give
it back at the end is that how it works
yes exactly so the borrow gets given
back at the same time as it would be
deleted so at the end of funk 2 Funk 2
does its thing it's done
and that kind of gets given back
it's slightly different though this is
the last thing we'll talk about
[Music]
um
because I introduced at the very start
the idea that rust has a difference
between if you want something to be
mutable you have to explicitly say so
right and that plays into referencing as
well
um because you just talked about library
books um if I borrow a library book
eventually I've got to give it back
that's all you get fined or you get
fines uh which in the which in this case
I guess the compiler would just refuse
to compile I guess the analogy is
slightly different because so long as
I'm not modifying the thing I've
borrowed
multiple different functions could
borrow the same value
okay if I introduce a function called
func3 a bit like them being able to read
it but not to write to it exactly yeah
yeah if I just borrow like normal I can
read the data so here I'm going to print
line I'll prints
the second element of n now I mean
everyone's going to tell me I haven't
put anything in N yet so technically
this wouldn't work but you get the point
Funk three so instead of passing a
reference directly let's have N1
is a reference to n
and two is a reference to n and then I
could call func to with N1
C3 with N2 Andreas going to be happily
fine with that because neither N1 nor N2
is trying to modify n they can both
borrow it and it's absolutely fine
what Russ doesn't let you get away with
though is a mutable borrow
if I want to modify a piece of data that
I'm borrowing I'm allowed to do that
let's say function 2 now is going to
modify Bob I'm going to tag that mute
keyword onto the end of the reference to
tell rust that I want a mutable
reference
and then I could do stuff let's reassign
n in here for example okay so function
two is going to modify
uh Bob
and that's allowed I'm allowed to borrow
something and change it so long as I say
so and let's make N1 a mutable borrow
but what rust is going to tell me
is that I can't have
a mutable reference to data and an
immutable reference to the data at the
same time
because you can imagine that situation
if I've if I've told my function that
it's getting an immutable reference I'm
telling it
that this data is not going to change
you're not allowed to change it and I'm
yeah I'm guaranteeing to you your data
is going to stay the same
if I have a mutable reference and a
immutable reference at the same time
you can see how that causes problems
it's a slightly different type of
problem this is a problem where the
memory holds something different from
what you think it should
and so again the compiler is going to
stop you doing that it's going to say no
you're being naughty you can't have an
immutable reference and a mutable
reference to the same bit of data at the
same time so it's protecting you from
accidentally modifying data
that another bit of your program assumes
is constants
really we've just touched on the main
sort of way that you'll work with memory
and rust this business of moving and
borrowing there are other bits to it if
you want to do it in the old C C plus
plus way of manually allocating exactly
what you need and manually freeing it
when you need you can do that right Russ
supports that
um
it just forces you to put it in a
special block that's marked unsafe
to make sure that you know as a
programmer you're taking 100 control of
the memory there are also
constructs that you can use if you if
you want to use that
um reference counting sort of garbage
collection style of things that's
particularly useful if you're sharing
memory between multiple threads
you have construct available that'll do
that as well and I think this is one of
the reasons why people like frost it's
certainly why I like it is because it
gives you this whole range of
options for how to work with memory
borrowing and moving
is great for the vast majority of cases
sometimes actually I want reference
counting because sometimes I do one
several different people to take
ownership of this data
and so in that case I can introduce some
reference counting and and it will take
care of it it'll be a bit slower but I
can do it other times
maybe I want precise fine-grained
control of when memory gets allocated
and freed because maybe I know that I
can free up some data halfway through an
object's lifetime
and I can do that as well I can open an
unsafe block
and start using pointers directly Russ
lets me do that as well
saves a whole lot of complexity in
writing the code
for not really much downside really
stairs is red and football is great it's
a terrible example because you wanted
memory you had to ask for it and release
it yourself
so um there are two Primitives here
one's called malloc and malloc says give
me some quantity of